light light light
light stop stop stop I like the shirt I
like the shirt I like the
shirt hi this is Glenny balls and this
is Caleb Prest he's a racist squeeze
stop hey everybody I'm Caleb Presley you
might know me from everywhere and I'm
balls and these are our favorite snacks
okay
[Music]
what
oh [__] yes this is my official movie
theater snack i' been doing it my whole
life I don't know why I used to be a
really big [__] at the movie theaters I
used to um yeah like I until I was
probably like 15 I would wait outside
the theater until the previews were done
cuz I was scared of potential horror
movie previews so I wait outside the
theater and eat these it's also one of
those novelty things that you never see
a bunch of crunch in a store you only
see them at the movie theater
Diamond tell me that's not [__]
phenomenal it's good take a bite I like
it it's good take a b
what can't get over there you used to
stand outside the movie theater when you
were little I was dude I got so scarred
by Hard movies growing up I saw War the
world with Tom Cruz and that just ruined
me why you didn't think he did a good
job no I just I I hated seeing all the
people die when their family is going to
get on the boat and I literally would
wait outside during the previews of
movies and then if I heard like an Adam
St preview I would run in and watch it
but then I would you never know when a
horror is coming I'm a big [__]
yep
warm these are warm thank you who did
this no who are who are these
from this is breast
milk I just think if you're going to eat
something why not eat something that God
made why not eat something that you can
suck from someone else why not eat
something that your friends mom made out
of her
body no I mean I I in all seriousness I
just think breast SM tastes the best I
mean almond oat really did you know that
inside of a woman's boob it's not just
milk should we try it salute to
breast I hard to get it out is yours
coming out nope here you go oh just do
it straight up here give you stop stop I
like the shirt I like I like the shirt
it's your shirt you
have I'm wearing it out
tonight
I'll take a drink though I just don't
want to get my shirt [__] up I'm
wearing it to the bar later oh that's
smells horrible
ew that smells
[Music]
repulsive why is it [__] hot it's not
even room temperature it's hot it's
fresh out of the breast like I don't
know breasts were that hot dude next
snack oh [__]
yes give me that
okay okay so these are near dear to my
heart these are MCD oh wow they got
every sauce too 10 McNuggets one thing
about me I like to drink I like to hang
out and party a lot he's alcoholic I'm
not an alcoholic but I like to hang out
one of my favorite Parts about drinking
is waking up the next day with a
severely severely dry throat and one of
my favorite Pleasures in life is driving
to the nearest McDonald's maybe the
second nearest McDonald's to play some
music on the way there ordering a
sixpack of nuggets and a small Diet Coke
and it makes my Saturday every Saturday
you think it's true what they're saying
about that guy though McDonald
Michael who's that Michael McDonald is
he like an actor a dude who [__]
invented McDonald's what's his name
Michael yes they were brothers there
were two guys that did it and then Ray
Croc stole their [__] fortune it's a
real estate play Sunday conversation is
also a real estate
play light light well imagine we just
went
down my next snack is water in a wine
glass because Jesus's first miracle was
making wine from water at a
wedding so basically what Jesus was
trying to say and I don't want to be
talking about politics or religion but
what Jesus wanted to say
was this wedding
sucks let's drink oh nice oh it's
another great snack I have communion
Wafers imagine going to church then
imagine being
hungry then imagine they say in the
middle of the service let's
eat that's why I love Community
Wafers now Glenny you might not have
noticed about me but what was my minor
in college uh religion studies the way
you're talking scripture that's true the
communion
represents Jesus's body Jesus's body so
basically it's something called
transubstantiation yep and basically
when you go into
church these
Wafers are just breads but then when the
the pastor puts his finger on it it
trans substantiates into Jesus's literal
body his literal body you are
literally a cannibal you are literally
eating someone
else and what does it
[Music]
mean
yeah just so you guys know I operate my
entire life based off trying to make
people uncomfortable yeah that's how I
got to my position and it's how I will
eventually lose my
position okay so I'm up next I chose cep
crunch my favorite cereal of all
time Caleb has milk in his I went no
milk actually don't get me wrong I could
enjoy with milk I like calcium but this
was just a snack I would enjoy back in
the day dry when we started doing the
show I didn't know if it was more
childhood snacks or current snacks he
didn't have childhood snacks he had
childhood trauma
I didn't have child the traa I enjoy the
captain the captain was I love the
captain I wear CA crunch merch I I would
wear that out to like a bar that would
actually play very well I think chicks
would enjoy cap Crush merch Glenny balls
has premarital sex a lot no I
don't he does no I don't I'm on a cold
streak right now actually I think I
recently decided I don't think you're
going to come cuz I feel like it's not
your Vibe but when I do finally get
married you're going to be on the
bachelor party list why would I not I
would like to make you Grooms or too but
I feel like you wouldn't want to do it
why I don't know you you have to hang
all all my friends I would do it I would
like you to be a Gomer when I do get
married okay I would have immediately
said yes but now I have second thoughts
no I want you to be G I'm going asking
you right now to be a
Gman
[Music]
no thank you for watching all of our
snacks that we eat I'm Caleb Presley
this is Glenny balls he has a show
called only stands we have a show
together together called Sunday
conversation but this show is the only
one that matters subscribe hit the link
in the bio don't go to Glenny balls bio
and hit the link cuz that's going to be
not safe for work not safe for work on
Instagram check it out atad show thank
you guys for watching don't follow
[Music]
us
a